last week 16 year-old heaven fish became
the first female fighter to win a state
championship in North Carolina she
absolutely smashed the boys and as
somebody who was raised on Buffy the
Vampire Slayer
I could not be happier but why is it the
girls still aren't encouraged to pursue
physical strength and ability as much as
boys I mean seriously the power
imbalances existed between men and women
forever historically stem from a
difference in strength and we're
choosing to add to that come on let me
be blunt if you tell your little boy to
be strong but not your little girl
you're saying to your children I only
want one of you to be able to defend
yourself in future as far as I'm
concerned that's child neglect accepting
the fantastic example that we've just
seen on screen and of course noting that
and commending it do you not accept that
the average man is going to probably be
not emotionally necessary but physically
stronger than the average one you don't
accept that
I accept that baby same premise now do
you therefore accept that while
everything should be done and if young
girls want to become body lifters weight
lifters whatever it might be that is
fantastic we must be just allow for what
nature has rightly or wrongly crew I
don't want shaking it up do you think
the average woman is stronger than the
atma don't quote an average means but
you honestly think that for a long time
people thought in sport that there was a
difference in muscle composition between
men and women what we're looking for is
this quick twitch fast twitch muscle
which explains elite performance in
things where you need spurts of strength
so weightlifting boxing explosive energy
a study last year found that that is no
it's not true they looked at the muscle
composition of elite female weight
lifters and they found that there was no
difference they had exactly the same
proportion of fast twitch muscle in some
cases high
there's a woman could beat Tyson Fury so
what we're finding is that the science
is just catching up with the idea that
there actually is no reason actually in
terms of gender why there should be a
difference in strength it's how you're
trained and it's also what you're taught
to think about your own capable let's
have a look at a proper match now I want
a good clean fight with you too you get
in your positions
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
regardless of whether or not there's a
physiological difference in women and
women the fact is even if we were to
accept that so that men are always going
to on average be slightly stronger even
if we accept that you why are we telling
our boys to pursue physical strength
with the best way to address that in
theory actually logically would be to
tell girls more than boys to pursue
physical strength in order to fix that
in well obviously one hole I was really
trying as well on that Greg I think Greg
let me win is a part of me that actually
thinks that do you think Maria Sharapova
could be no science whatsoever but I do
think that on the average an average man
would be stronger than your average
woman but I don't understand this
obsession with trying to make men and
women the same I think that actually you
know it's not about for me when I if I
had a girl or a boy I would want those
children to be as physically I went to
karate from being five years of age my
whole childhood I did and I would want
my child to be able to self defend I
think that's really important whether
you're a girl or a boy and if my child
was into sports I would want to
encourage that as much as possible
irrespective of their gender so I think
as a parent if you put your own kid into
your girls the girls sit there and play
with a doll you're a boy go do
weightlifting then I think that's you've
been silly as a parent and and we and
research shown done by a woman in sports
shows that seventy six percent of boys
felt they were encouraged by their
parents to pursue physical strength
whereas just sixty seven percent of
girls felt the same you are creating an
imbalance well your worsening and
imbalance in society and it's just not
good there's a stat from women in sports
anyway I would say something quite
profound but we just said that 28% of
girls aged 14 to 16 enjoy playing sport
we're boys the figures much great I
don't think I just think it's about the
socialization of what happens I think
you're right about the socialization so
even when we look at people who are at
the top of their game so Andrea Petkovic
who's a German tennis player she's
ranked 82 in the world she says about
muscles
I just feel and feminine I feel like
there are millions of people who watch
me on TV who think I look like a
bodybuilder because of my muscular
physique I would love to be a confident
player that is proud of her body but as
a woman
we are judged more our physicality is
judged more and it makes us
self-conscious so even someone at the
top of their game thinks that I think
there is a lot of socialization around
that so women feel like developing
muscle and being strong is in some way
unfeminine I think that is a
socialization we separate the ideas of
what a boy should pursuing what go
pursue pursue right from an early age
therefore you put the boys in these more
rough-and-tumble sports so that boys
grow up thinking that the way they
should judge people is that is on their
ability to survive in those sorts of
games I judging people based on their
physical strength and and that will well
right now disadvantaged women and you
were agree with what I'm about to say
but I think in society women are
conditioned to what is socially
acceptable based on what is attractive
to men that's what I think so I think as
a woman you have this image I don't know
you probably won't agree but as a woman
there you're pushed images about what is
sexy and attractive and it is all based
on what men perceive to be attractive
the water in his swimming trunks it's
not the same about strength
you coming
so the media plays a massive role in
what we find sexy so what was what were
considered to be attractive a hundred
years ago would be a much more much more
full of woman worlds whereas right
networks right now thanks to especially
magazines and fashion a thinner woman
and then now we've moved in the JLo
direction and with with more curves it
changes based on what we've gone from
Cary Grant to Daniel Craig it's the same
for both sexes but the fact is if we if
we were to encourage women to pursue
sport if that was if a more masculine
was was portrayed in in the media in
films as the attractive female in those
storylines it would change the
perception of as to what we perceive as
sexy remember you're coming from a
culture I mean where the Football
Association's 50 years it was ladylike
and you think now you look at what's
happened in recent years where there's
some very good people working in women's
football who managed to get hold of
quite a lot of money out of the FA and
actually the growth in women's it's
enormous compared to the growth in men's
football mammy and it's about culture oh
just to be blunt I just want a world
where are they in the mind of every
single creep out there the thought that
girl might kick my ass is bedded and
into their head so and thanks for the
ongoing saga of brexit you would be
forgiven for thinking that politics is
well boring but it seemed like hope was
on the horizon in the form of the race
to be the next Labour leader after all
who could forget the 2010 contest the
ultimate sibling scandal when David
Miliband dear brother Edie stole the job
from right under his nose or the shot
victory in 2015 when Oh Jeremy Corbyn
took the reigns after a fiercely fought
fight between the left and the left er
than left but the contest in 2020 looks
set to go down in history as the dullest
one ever
whether it's long baleen Andy or sir
stormer who end up as the Honorable
leader of the Opposition it's safe to
say that this contest hasn't provided
the light-hearted relief we were all
hoping for until now step 4 the often
overlooked deputy leadership race take a
look at Doc and ER doctor Rosina Eileen
Khan's unique way of topping off a
closing statement you've still got
another 25
[Applause]
[Music]
we're single-handedly managing to save
us from certain boredom dr. Regina you
are our parliamentary pop star of the
week that's all we've got time for this
week but if you want to join in the
debate just search for us on Twitter or
check out the Sky News Facebook page and
if you want to listen on the go you can
find the pledge podcast on Apple Google
or Spotify thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time
[Music]